it's an 82 year old woman in Henderson
apparently dying while waiting for
repairs to her air conditioning unit now
the family has found a wrongful death
lawsuit Brian will joining us now live
after speaking to a family member
earlier today Brian
good evening Denise Virginia desapio was
found here in her Henderson home dead
after days without air conditioning
temperatures inside that home reaching
120 degrees
always remember going over to her her
house and she made this incredible iced
tea the best iced tea I've ever had in
my life Greg Kelly remembers his aunt
Virginia de sapio as a loving aunt and a
great neighbor who is always timely and
neat with her home but on a hot summer
day last August a neighbor who walked
around and found her passed away along
with her beloved dog Jesse the sapio and
her dog were found dead on August 22nd
2022 the death certificate says she died
as a result of environmental heat stress
caused by prolonged exposure to elevated
ambient temperatures inside her home it
also indicates she had lung cancer to
see the word cause of death you know
accidental it was unnecessary the sapios
air conditioning went out on August 11th
and documents show she filed a claim
that same day with her home warranty
company Fidelity National home warranty
under Nevada law that company is is
required to fix it within 24 hours and
if in three days they can't then they
have to let the person know the status
they failed on every level for her every
time they set up an appointment they
canceled it they canceled it after they
were supposed to be there for the
appointment then they put her complaint
her her claim on hold even though they
had accepted it and then after they put
it on hold they would just say oh never
mind we're setting another appointment
oh we're canceling it and then finally
they said well we're researching a
pricing issue but never told her we
won't be able to fix your air
conditioner on August 24th two days
after she was found dead the company
said the estimated completion for the
repair would be on August 31st They
delayed it again on August 31st and
again on September 1st the repair to the
AC unit was finally complete on
September 5th about two weeks after her
death they took her premium payment and
then failed to come up to their end of
the bargain when it was the time we
wanted to find out exactly what happened
now we've reached out to that company
for comment and have yet to hear back
live in Henderson Brian will eight news
now